voilà ce que ça signifie bien ce qui
nous attend bientôt d'excusés
aujourd'hui un titre avec mika pour
jouer non pas un jeu vidéo mais un jeu
de foudre on va morfler injuste sado
maso après de sado maso exactement on
est sur lightning réaction au bureau son
boys tech après le succès du genre de
chaises musicales
on tient chacun une somme de petits
mangent dans notre main comme ceci est
juste un bouton dessus voilà il ya une
musique qui se lancent et dès qu'elle
s'arrête il faut appuyer et celui qui
appuie le moins rapidement se prend une
décharge électrique
il ya quatre niveaux d'électricité là
c'est sûr le niveau rend non plus mais
on va pas prendre très cher aux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya un courant qui se passe entre les
eaux et là on va c'est moi ou pas avec
des mots de hockey lna
le but c'est pas de la chine que couture
quand même un peu plus longtemps que
justin voilà je vais refaire le but
c'est vraiment le terrain ça mange ce
que le couturier assez long et dur quoi
entre une et deux secondes bon on voit
ça ou pas les ballons et nous on sent
bien et si tu appuies avocat musique
s'arrête c'est la décharge
[Musique]
évidemment il faut déjà qu'on s'a
vraiment je les déteste ce n est en fait
pas si je partageais pas le faire
ok non non c'est un choix non mais tu là
je me fais une solution veilleux de
lâcher quoi ouais se scotcher la main
comme d'un fouet et ont été vos 4 allez
on y va on y va comme ça
ah qu'est ce qu'on m'a scotché au fond
de cette boîte et voilà comme ça il peut
plus retirer s'habitue et la plume de
plus c'est bon tu es cannet saison avec
les dents ouais on a maintenant tous les
deux on a ce côté d'un mec tu peux
partir est tellement ça veut dire même
si tu si on est on est sûr de la 2 sur 4
ha sera violent mais ça passe tu as il
faut pas les il faut animer une vidéo me
casse tu veux oui mais je l'espère
derrière et c'est ben c'était pas fort
basse et 2004 non ce qui veut dire que
c'est la perspective
[Musique]
moi je te prends direct reste fair-play
on se tient la main c'est comme les
vraies fermes anciens docks d'oreilles
se jaugeaient ouest à la fin comme j'ai
un doute mais je me sens bien à vos
peacemaker mec je pas le 10 mai coeur
mais ça m'a fait mal au cul rien là bas
mais regardez ils cassent tout lieu quoi
c'est pas drôle enfin rangement moi toi
ça trompe alors ça mais voilà vous
deviez vous avec mon petit doigt sa
porte se sentent l'âme et fonctionne
comme ça tu es vraiment la merde
une petite crotte de chien auquel me
cachais proposer un truc ya un mode où
c'est le plus rapide qui ne se prend pas
la décharge soit ya eu une tentative
d'attentât est ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va en prendre le deux chacun et ce
qui veut dire que dans tous les cas tu
prends au moins une décharge attente est
très doué mais combien de mètres de
trucs par match qui fait qu'elle est
dans tous les cas dans le meilleur des
cas tu te prends quand même une décharge
d'un truc et dans le pire tu t'en prends
les deux les deux monsieurs au niveau
d'électricité lebel et un sur quatre
mais à lens on nous l'annonçait le
mercato
iluv ce match d'hier soir c'est plus
pareil que les deux s'arrache témoin pas
aller à la plaisanterie
ce que j'aime faire face non lucratif
mais non mais je te sens tu verras la
remettre ici tu vas mourir on regarde
ouailles à metz le jeu devenu pour les
crimes et la bouffe on est vraiment
génial c'est à dire que c'est d'une des
violences jeudi l'espace le temps et
leurs plus hauts la trêve rien matt a pu
faire autrement que guy hachey il a
indiqué on va plus l'électricité doit
non mais attends à ce qu il sait ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui de riches alors
appliquent la peine d'électricité ceci
est la peine de triche 2 1 ceci est le
sort réservé à ceux qui trichent les
quatre dans une main quelles nouvelles 4
qui vous attend si j'ai pas touché tu
vas tu on est tous souffert
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est abuser les cas comment décrire un
jeu en vidéo web manager c'est la fin de
cette vidéo sur ce petit jeu qui
s'appelle retrouve la boîte
l'interaction voilà et moi j'ai fini
avec les mêmes cheveux que lui mais j'ai
agi au début de la vidéo et ses
conseillers d'avoir et c'est je n'ai pas
comprise une blague voilà on a bien
douillet est devenu c'était assez court
mais c'est que bon on se prendre des
coups de vue ça va bien cinq minutes à
la maison voilà l'amusement mersa au
regard des nestes et fait mais la vidéo
ça vous a plu
en tout cas ça fait du bien sûr de
s'affronter finalement et de te voir
souffrir comme un gros porc moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé être sauf à se trouve très
vite dans une prochaine vidéo déjà du
monde vis à vis
voilà quoi adieu les gros 4 est
terrifiée à djebbour a qualifié plus
tard
solution savez comme moi
[Musique]